these are the men now calling the shots
in the yemeni capital sana the booty
rebel fighters have set up roadblocks
throughout the city they're celebrating
their victories but their power grab has
not gone according to plan earlier this
week they squeezed concessions out of
president Hardy after over running the
presidential palace the next day Hadi's
government resigned leaving a sudden
power vacuum the rebels had not reckoned
with president hardy followed suit but
Parliament refused to accept his
resignation Yemen is in the Middle East
poorest country and its problems
political and economic are mounting
they're not all homegrown experts say
the Shiite booties are supplied with
money and weapons by Iran while Saudi
Arabia has provided support for Yemen's
Sunni president it's a proxy war with
dire consequences for the population
many ordinary people here have had
enough on Thursday hundreds protested in
tears what's happening here is a farce a
coup that is completely unconstitutional
there are fears that al-qaeda could
exploit the power vacuum that's a
frightening proposition the group's
yemen offshoot is considered the most
dangerous in the world